all right
we are now live for another political
theory and practice
discussion i've been bouncing this one
from weekend to weekend to weekend in
part because i was hoping
that our situation here in the united
states would be
more or less resolved and we're ready to
start
moving ahead and that does not
entirely seem to be the case but
you know i wanted to get this in before
christmas
so i don't have any any notes prepared
but i've been thinking a lot about these
these topics that i want to discuss i
see we've got some good questions
already
on the side so i might not go quite as
long in the
initial discussion part so
um you know we're now a month and a half
roughly from one of our most contentious
and
indeed you know from a very hyper
partisan perspective
uh contested elections we
are still seeing uh on the republican
side
among some people at least the the trump
and his his
administration and uh quite a few
other republicans who publicly
hitched their wagon to that star of the
lawsuits
um you know claims that uh
the election was not um
you know a legitimate one in one way or
another that voter fraud took place all
this sort of stuff
and so you know we don't we we have not
had an orderly succession
we have instead had uh a contestation
and in effect attempts to turn
various uh workings of of
democracy here in the united states you
know people looking at
from the outside um i think a lot of
americans particularly those
on the right are not realizing how crazy
and how problematic this becomes and i i
will say one other thing too
about this um beforehand i think a lot
of americans this is a bit of a tangent
assume that not only are we the center
of the universe
but also that you know things have to
uh be be you know um
there has to be sort of like a
continuation of america as
having the the prestige and power that
we currently have
and this is a version of american
exceptionalism that you can find on both
sides of the political
aisle and a lot in the center as well
and there's just nothing to say when you
look at world history there's nothing to
say that any one particular
culture civilization nation state will
outlast its its internal problematics
and the things that are bringing it
under particularly when it's facing
pressure and rivalry from other great
powers that that
are aiming at hegemony and you know
we're
in a bad so i'm going to say this we're
in a bad state here in the united states
and it's been going on for a long time
covet 19 has been totally mishandled
particularly at the federal level but
also at many states levels
and in many institutions as well and
kovid 19 just in in many respects
revealed the many cracks
running through the the substructure of
american society
things that we're going to have to deal
with things that we're going to have to
have some sort of coming together
or you know pushing some voices to the
fringe
and and achieving a consensus or we're
screwed
and and that's that's the bottom line
for that that sort of so that's that's
my view
we're going to talk about um you know
some political theory that i think
helps to illuminate that in just a bit
particularly aristotle and
and thomas hobbes um
but going back to the election itself i
think it's a very bad sign for us
that not only you know the election was
so contested and so close
even with um you know a lot of uh
efforts at uh keeping people from being
able to vote
and and things like that going on i
think that
it's it's a bad sign as well that
we keep ratcheting up the the
partisanship
you know part of having a functional
democracy
is saying okay we lost now
move on and you know granted the trump
people can say
well the hillary people didn't do that
you know they they were shouting not my
president
well you know the trump people pretty
much all of them are are
you know people who well actually no
quite a few of them did vote for obama
uh when when obama won uh there there
was that that shedding
in important states like here in
wisconsin
but quite a few of them are people who
are like saying obama wasn't their
president either and then you know we go
back and there were a lot of people were
saying george bush wasn't their
president
in part because of the you know
constitutional crisis we could say
uh that that almost emerged out of
2000. so we've got like 20 years now of
this hyper partisan
tear it all down fight you know take
power at any cost
and it hasn't just been the republicans
doing that
over that 20-year period and you can
observe this not just within our
electoral politics but also
in what's been happening within our
legislatures
so a lot of problematic stuff going on
and if we
want to see the sorts of things that
as americans were going to need going
forward to be a
functional um you know
democratic rule of law uh
society you're gonna need a lot of
reconstruction
and i think there's i i'm not very
optimistic
about that on a national level i'm gonna
you know myself
here's where the practice comes in even
if we're pessimistic about that sort of
stuff
we still throw ourselves into things i
mean i'm gonna be
you know once the once we've actually
got a succession um one of the things
i'm gonna be pushing for is medicare for
all
and trying as best as i can as a private
citizen to hold the biden people to the
to the fire about that um and that's the
sort of thing that you can do you can be
involved in your local politics you know
um
our our you know milwaukee city council
stuff is kind of uh
a hot mess to watch but it's worth
checking
in on you know there's there's a lot of
things that we we can do
um so one of the things that i did want
to talk about
before we get into talking about like
aristotle and hobbes
is so biden we i think we can take it
for granted
that unless there is some sort of coup
um biden
is going to be you know the president
we're gonna have a biden administration
he's already got cabinet members lined
up
and surprise surprise a lot of these
cabinet members are former deputy
deputy director of this or that cabinet
under the obama administration it looks
very much like a
obama you know 2.0 kind of uh
administration and it's very important
to remember too that the president
in the united states with the exception
of
you know outliers like donald trump the
presidency is usually
not just the president kind of going it
alone
it's all the people who they they pick
to run things the cabinet right
that's very important and so
if we want to see what what the biden
administration's commitments are
then we look at who they put in as you
know secretary of the interior secretary
of agriculture
secretary of state all these different
uh important positions
and you know for the most part it does
look like a pretty
centrist regime that's going to be
coming in
which means that they're not very
interested in the things that
the leftist democrats i think quite
rightly
as myself an independent uh i think that
they're
on the right point with that with saying
we need to do something about
you know um you know more fair tax
burdens which means taxing the rich more
um you know closing loopholes um
providing some sort of universal health
care
uh you know a number of different
different things i think the advantage
administration
biden administration is going to have to
be really really pushed
on a lot of those things and when you do
that then there's this
tendency to say oh but then you're like
playing into the hands of the right
and you know if you criticize them this
is what went on during the obama years
right
if you're criticizing uh from from
further left and saying these are the
positions you should have
then you're giving ammunition to the the
opposition and
that is a big problem um i think that
uh we need to figure out a way to to see
our way
past that there's also this big thing
going on within the
um i'm seeing some stupid comments here
so i'm gonna do a little bit of uh
hiding some of these
these um so
you know i'm i'm uh seeing a lot of
calls for
including from the biden administration
unity and it strikes me that right now
i understand why there's a rhetorical
appeal for that
but that strikes me as kind of a stupid
way to go about things
you know it's very clear looking back
you know say a decade or so that the
republicans are going to do the same
thing as they did during the obama
administration and try to like
hold stuff up as much as possible and
get in as many
uh you know shots against the the
administration to try to delegitimize it
and prepare for a run in in 2024
and so i don't think that there really
should be a lot of compromise i think
the democrats should play hardball as
much as possible
um you know the question is whether
they're going to play hardball for stuff
that's genuinely for the people or
whether they're going to
play hardball more for their own
interests or their own conception of
that
but i i don't think that there should be
any like let's try to understand the
trump you know voter
that we've already done four years of
that you know um
and and a lot of it is not a desire to
be understood
on their part the trump you know uh
people it's it's more a desire to
dominate and control
and to win by any means necessary and i
think with people like that
there's really not that much that you
can do so
let's uh talk very briefly about
some of the the before i take some of
these questions some of the
issues that i think are are
really worth uh thinking about here
so you know aristotle's politics
should be recommended reading as should
hobbes leviathan
and when you read hobbs leviathan
correctly
instead of in a sort of hysteric kind of
oh we don't want totalitarianism
you know we don't want the the sovereign
to be in place kind of mode
and you're you look carefully at what
he's actually saying
hobbes is very worried and rightly so
because he lived through an english
civil war
about the the ways in which
different factions can use the language
of political theory and theology
and all these other things to
essentially
try to grab power for themselves in such
a way that that plays into a dynamic
that then destabilizes matters you know
and i i've written on this
not so much with american politics but
with with other
uh politics you could easily google the
stuff i've written on hobbs
and i i'm convinced that that hobbes
worry about the state of nature is
really more of a rhetorical construct
what he's really concerned about
is um a not so
healthy commonwealth breaking down
because
of all these rivalries and factions
that are able to you know co-opt certain
certain
let's call them dimensions of society
right and so his his
uh response that is well you need a
powerful sovereign to control that
and to break any sort of private
associations like that
and then to have a monopoly on power i'm
not advocating that
but i think that hobbes rightly
identifies
the the problematic that we are we've
been sliding into for for quite a while
here in america aristotle is also
somebody who people should read
and if you want to understand
um how things go wrong look at book five
of the politics which is about you know
what he calls stasis
which we can translate as faction or
societal breakdown
a lot of the dimensions that he's
talking about including passionate
dimensions
anger hatred uh envy all these sorts of
things
play a role in it um
[Music]
grievances that have not been properly
addressed
that people are exploiting um
those play a role in in societal
breakdown
now i'm not saying we're we're like you
know like a step away from that or
anything like that i mean there are
people
who think oh we're like one step away
from civil war i think we we've got
we could come back from the brink but
it's not going to happen with anything
that's being offered on the right
and i don't see much being offered by
the current
position of the obama again the biden
administration um i don't see i don't
see an
awful lot that's going to be productive
i see them
being a little bit too idealistic about
about this
this sort of thing so i you know i'm
really interested to see
how they're going to govern and where
they can be steered towards you know
um following through on things that are
traditionally
you know some of these are traditionally
like nowadays democrat issues but
they're they're also conservative issues
like not
not screwing up the environment that
used to actually be a conservative thing
um the conservatives today are not
really that conservative because they
haven't conserved conservativism you
could say
in some of its some of its respects i
mean it's good to keep in mind these are
these are coalitions all right let's
take a look at some of these
questions that are are arising
um zach says how do you deal with
incredibly racist parents in general
trying to explain why trump is racist
never goes well since they just call me
a liberal
how do we move forward with thoughts
like these so there's a lot of people in
these sorts of
um
quandaries i would say and
i i don't think that you're really going
to make much progress
in trying to discuss things with people
whose minds are already not just
closed in a static way but who are
constantly
being fed garbage um by
the the social media the traditional
media that they are
imbibing um narratives that are very
um sophisticatedly put out there i i
don't think it's you know this is not
the 1960s where if you had a john
bircher
in your family you could like
essentially cult deprogram them
um there's it's a lot tougher
and so much of it is also tied in with
like geography
and demographics you know if you here in
milwaukee if you drive into
waukesha county you will see
significant differences in the way that
people are behaving
and what they're saying what they're
doing and that's just one county over
and that's an
urbanized county for the most part but
it's the republican capital
of this state of wisconsin and it ties
in with things like
masking and social distancing because
that has become a politicized issue it
shouldn't have become
but it has unfortunately as will
vaccinations right
um and so
i think with with people like that you
know what you can do
is is if you want to retain connections
with them
you can try to not talk politics and
just and
that probably means you know opting out
of some conversations and not spending
that much time with
with them you know and you also want to
start looking for
other people who you can have productive
conversations with
you know it's sad but
there's there's a lot of cases of family
members and i i've got
many many family members who are trump
supporters
uh because my family you know a good
portion of it is pretty redneck the kind
of rednecks that know the difference
between rednecks and hillbillies you
know
and um you know some of them are union
but a lot of union people are now
pro-trump depending on what kind of
union they're in
um so you know iron workers
great example of that a lot of them are
trumpers
what do you do well you you can talk
about
some things with them but other things
not i mean i've got an aunt who
is a registered nurse and doesn't wear a
mask
you know um that's how deep this this
this rot
has has gotten and so you know
i i i think what you have to do is
on the one hand think about what you're
going to do in relation to the people
who matter to you
who are essentially locked into their
position
and then think about what you're going
to do to develop your own
emotional connection and support work
to sustain yourself
um so kuftaka
asks a general question how should i
begin learning political theory and
studying influential
thinkers in the subjects i mean there's
no one single way
you could start in a chronological way
with reading
thucydides and plato and aristotle
and you know other other thinkers uh
throughout the ancient period you could
also expand it to
reading uh important um non-western
thinkers like khatilah
and um you know i mean everybody loves
sun tzu but
you know i think senzu's probably a
little bit elevated too high
in in the rankings i think there's
plenty of other theorists you can
read in chinese philosophy as well but
um i mean you can read all sorts of
things or you can jump to the present
and you know read your way backwards
almost you know like
you could pick up hana rents i mean if
you want a
work that you're going to have to work
at hana rent's origins of
totalitarianism which
got got sold you know as like a best
seller once trump came to power
um it's a tough book but if you actually
read it through
and then you follow up on some of the
footnotes you are going to get a
pretty good grounding so you know
there's
you could think of it as sort of a
lifelong
um and and there's there's all sorts of
you know zach gives a
a recommendation here there's all sorts
of like
sort of like survey texts that will give
you
um like here's what this theory is
here's what this theory is here's what
this theory is those are
nothing wrong with those just realize
they're always written from a
perspective um so you know they're
they're probably
skewed one way or the other
uh wolf would ask a question that he
thinks is tangential but i think is
actually
quite quite an interesting one um given
my academic background how do i see all
the fuss regarding jill biden's
doctorate
i think that um it's i mean it's pretty
clear to me that
um the the fuss you could say
is coming entirely from the right or
from
uh centrists who are just kind of
[ __ ] basically like the guy who
wrote the wall street journal
piece um i think is is just a prime
example of an [ __ ] you know you look
at the other stuff that he's written
um i mean
the the idea that medical doctors are
the only people who should be called
doctors is so
ahistorical and silly as to not be
worth taking seriously i mean when did
they when did they first start getting
called
medical doctors pretty recently right
whereas doctors you know uh somebody who
who can teach
that goes back to the to the middle ages
the early universities by the way had
three main degrees um
you know that there were terminal
degrees one was medicine
one was law one was theology and all of
them required that you study philosophy
and the liberal arts on the way you
wouldn't get to
just like specialize in medicine and so
it's kind of silly and it it's it's
frankly it's it's
it's clearly sexist and it's clearly
classist
um i mean i i think you could spend time
unpacking an argument why that's the
case but for me it's almost like
just right in your face um
nobody nobody quibbles about me calling
myself
you know dr sadler or anything like that
um and uh it's it's funny because there
are a lot of people out there
who do think oh if you're teaching at
harvard or university of chicago
that must be so much harder and requires
so much more
you know brain work than teaching at a
community college
no that's totally classist assumptions
based in
in unreality the people at harvard or
university of chicago are not any
smarter than any any other place i've
dealt with a lot of them
talent is about evenly distributed it's
really about class dynamics
and if you want to teach and you want to
do
hard work teach in a four-year program
teach in a two-year program because it's
easy to teach harvard kids
they come in they're all prepped to
learn and stuff like that
plus your teaching load is super super
easy right
um teaching in prisons and community
colleges and small four-year liberal
arts colleges
in adult education programs and stuff
like that
that's where the real hard teaching
takes place
and so you know
that's you know that's something to keep
in mind i
i would say
michael writes hard to find high-level
relevance like this
well i hope it's all relevant thanks
that's a nice uh compliment let's see
what the next one
is uh raheem would you recommend francis
fukiyama's works origins of political
order and it's decay i haven't read that
one
so um fukuyama is somebody i'm hoping
this current year to get back to
you know he made a big splash with end
of history in the last man which i still
think is actually quite
quite good in some respects and and i
might do some videos on that
and i think the last book i read by him
is our post-human future which was quite
good
but that that's dating it a good way so
i'm not i'm not really a great um
fukuyama person right all right rt
whitby hume said that philosophy was not
for the many but for the approbation of
the wise what do you think of this kind
of intellectual elitism that existed in
the past and still exists in philosophy
i would say that you know that's partly
representative of hume and partly not
representative of hume
you know i wouldn't take uh one one quip
as as like
the summary of his his work um there's a
lot of uh
work on on him not so much in political
philosophy but in moral philosophy that
was done in the
20th century um philosophy can be
elitist there are some things where
philosophy probably ought to be elitist
you know if somebody
we don't like take a vote on how to
interpret
you know hume's treaties or heidegger's
being in time
or um you know pick whatever you want
that would be ridiculous um but
you know we we should say that that
here's here's my take on this so
philosophy is elitist
in that there is a class system to it an
arbitrary one
and the problem with class systems is
not class systems as such it's that the
distinctions often are
not correlated to anything that really
ought to matter so like you know when we
engage in you know um racism right
um it's it's skin color and stuff like
that is usually
irrelevant to the moral decisions that
we need to make
um and so it's stupid to do that it's
it's irrational
and it's in some respect anti-human in
the sense that it goes against
what's available in our human nature and
we should develop
and in philosophy there's been an awful
lot of that you know
much of it is quite arbitrary
but i i you know
i think what we do is we figure out how
practically we're going to undo that
so a great example of this is there's a
lot of
contestations about canon what should
what should we be teaching
and you know when i'm setting up my my
um classes i do think about like who do
i want to bring
in that hasn't been taught before or who
doesn't typically get taught so i've
been teaching mary wollstonecraft for
years and years you're still you know if
you look at like histories of moral
philosophy
they mostly don't even recognize her or
you know marge cavenditch or you know
estelle
or any of these these people you gotta
like wait until the 20th century and
then they might talk about de bouvoir
and a rent
or they might not um so you know
bringing
bringing in theorists um
when it comes to like good solid
historical and practical work on the
people that i'm really interested in
like aristotle or the stoics
i would say that at least half of the
research is being done by women today
you know so you you you make sure that
you you signal you know gizella
striker's work
or julianis work you know and so you
know that
you can do practical things like that
and i think that that's helpful and also
you talk about
issues across the spectrum all right
all right um
michael leftman he's got a jija question
what do i think about ggx worry about
the left's ability to organize in a way
that could erect a stable governmental
system even if we're somehow overcome
neoliberalism i don't really give a [ __ ]
too much about what g-jek worries about
or stuff like that
um i i he's interesting to read once in
a while but
he's one of those people that i read
quite a bit of in graduate school and
i think that he you know he's an
academic celebrity
um and
why should we care anymore about what
g-jeck has to say than about what
other people who are studying the the
problem have to say i think
the the capacity for the left
particularly in america
to organize well and to not get drawn
off into all sorts of piddly [ __ ]
issues that that do matter but are not
centrally important um and to allow
themselves to be
marginalized in that way and then not
show solidarity with each other too
there's another big problem on the left
you know lack of solidarity
um i think these are real issues and you
don't have to go to g-shock to worry
about that i think we've got plenty of
ways to
theorize about that i remember when i
was at european graduate school where by
the way zhizhak every once in a while
teaches
i was there as a visiting scholar
because my wife was studying there
and they had heart and negri
and
one of them had to stay at the base of
the mountain and then the other one is
up there
and um it was heart and he was talking
about or you know
occupy wall street and how great it is
to have
not leadership and stuff like that and i
was
i was thinking about this and i was like
well how the hell does that help
anything
you have to have leadership you have to
have cadres you have to have
organization
in order to like get things done let
alone to like
reach out to other people if you're like
yeah man we're a leaderless movement you
know
um well then when you're trying to do
actual politics
who talks to you then how do you how do
you
work with um uh other
people who don't see things your way
right you have to have some sort of
leadership or something and so there's
there's a significant
problem there um glam
pantera are you afraid the precedent of
doubt and conspiracy trump is created by
his denial of the vote
will bring about problems in the future
i wouldn't say afraid
i but i would say that it's
guaranteed as a matter of fact i'm sure
that we're going to have problems
in the midterms and i think we're having
problems even with with the
i mean you can see this with the georgia
um senate runoffs right
where the republicans are now kind of
eating their own
if you're not extreme enough for them
then you've abandoned the cause
you know and you know i'll admit
i there's a bit of shot in freudia that
i take in watching that because i'm like
well you
you conspiracy theory bullshitters
really do deserve to eat your own but
it it on the other hand i look at it as
a more rational person i'm like
this is bad this is setting a really bad
precedent
um and i think it's going to lead to a
lot of like
you know people exploiting that
situation i think it's going to lead to
more violence
i think it's going to lead to hardening
of
of positions i think if trump cared at
all about the common good
once he saw that he'd lost he would have
like done what every other president
basically before him has done and said
you know and called up and said
okay i can i concede um and i think the
fact that he didn't do that
is a sign of terrible character and
selfishness on his part but i think he
also has lots and lots of people
unfortunately of terrible character
um or really damaged character
who uh think that's cool you know and
that that he should keep doing it and
what are we going to do with all these
people
that's that's a significant issue again
we i it's not like i'm going to do
anything with them because i'm not in
charge
right so all right vail
um
how do i think we should approach
conspiracies to maintain stable
democracy
there are way too many people who either
think uh the virus is a hoax election as
a fraud
i mean if it was up to me i would be
will i'd be perfectly willing to use
force to crack down
on people who want to
break the law if you have a mask mandate
and people violate it
then you know find them
jail them all that sort of stuff and if
the cops don't want to enforce it
get new cops fire them get rid of the
bad apples who
uh think the thin blue line is the way
to go as a matter of fact i think we
should
really across the board we should be
doing a lot of firing and rehiring
not not rehiring a lot of firing and new
hiring of police officers
um unfortunately that's not gonna happen
but that's that's what i would do if i
was in charge
there used to be this uh this radio uh
he's
actually in he's still on uh john
something in um
chicago i used to listen to this radio
station he would be on wgn
i'm not sure where he is now but he
would say if i was king for a day
and and you know then he would enact
these these uh
uh pronouncements right that he would do
if you were to leave it up to me i would
say
um this has now reached the point where
conspiracy theories are actually a
threat to
public health and law and order and
a lot of other things that we value and
so
tough [ __ ] for conspiracy theorists you
know
freedom of speech is not something that
we should allow to be
what do we want to say uh co-opted
by by conspiracy theories um but
i i don't see that that anybody's gonna
do much about that
uh neo asks what do i think of the
implications of a potential or
actual contesting of the certification
of the electoral votes
um i mean we've had
the last month and a half has been that
right
the i mean here's the implications
anything in this this long
decades uh you know long breakdown
of the capacity to work with each other
that both political parties have had
anything that that one group
starts to do as precedent the other
group can like do it after them
and they'll [ __ ] and whine about it but
they don't really have any grounds for
doing it i mean we are
in a much worse position politically
in in the possibility of attaining
consensus on important things and
enacting legislation that we need
uh than we were 20 or 40 years ago
and it's because of irresponsible
actions
like you know all these lawsuits and
contesting things
it is just uh you know selfish
foolish behavior then again you know
there's no guarantee that america is
gonna like remain
a viable democracy right so yeah
um prohem says as a progressive do you
think the moderate dems like nancy
pelosi buy to need criticism or are they
doing their best in a broken system
are radical policies necessary even if
they're unrealistic i'm not a
progressive to begin with
you know i'm an independent and i'm
pretty cynical about politics and
in general if you've followed me for a
long time you know that i was a severe
critic of the obama administration
uh on a number of different points and
sometimes it's progressive and sometimes
it's because i'm
too traditional to be a conservative or
what passes for conservatives these days
so i do think that there are some big
picture things that we
absolutely need to have and they look
like progressive policies like you know
you know uh we need we need some sort of
revamped nationwide healthcare system
that's just a given neither side really
seems to want to do it the republicans
are against it for all sorts of stupid
[ __ ] reasons
including like you know claims about
you're not going to be able to choose
your doctor
and a lot of it is just you know the
wish to be [ __ ] on their part like i
don't want other people getting health
care
you know um and just a lack of
priorities i mean we blow so much on on
national defense we could carve out a
little bit of that and
solve so many problems uh and then on
the democrat side so many of them are
beholden to the system the way it is and
and they don't suffer from the effects
of it
i mean if you've been on the the
affordable health the affordable care
act which we are my
wife and i as self-employed people
it is not like a handout it's not easy
to use it's expensive
it requires a lot of work a lot of hours
like
filling out forms and sometimes things
still don't get covered
and that's the best thing that the
democrats produce and that's the
the amount that's what the the
republicans were willing to go along
with
we need some serious health care stuff
otherwise the next pandemic is going to
kill us
you know if we don't fix things
if you want to call that progressive we
can call that progressive and i think
that yeah we we criticize the
democratic leadership for falling down
on the job and being beholden to the
insurance companies and
you know we can say the same thing with
defense you know
why why do we see all these defense
lobbyists getting brought into the
the the uh once again i was almost gonna
say obama administration
and to the biden administration i mean
and anything that we criticize the
the biden administration for we don't
let the republicans off the hook either
you know we say you're you're you you
people are like
really degenerate and doing some
terrible things and you need to get your
your house in order great example of
this ron johnson our
our senator here in wisconsin i don't
care who they put up against him i'll be
voting against him
in 2022 and you may have seen my
hashtags you know voter on out 2022.
i'll be doing that at the same time i'll
also be you know
calling his office and saying hey you
guys are screwing up you need to change
your position
we need to think about things in a multi
not not necessarily like one single
solution
politics is all about this like multi
multi-approach
grinding away it's like a war of
attrition
but a war of attrition that can be done
you know for
uh human interests the interests of of
people who
need a functioning political system and
economic system and all these things
or for private interests you know
all right uh alex asks what do you think
of the ruling class divide between
factions of long-term stability between
short-term profit new and old
money i think that's pretty much
irrelevant at this time i think
you know old money is also interested in
short-term profit
and how the working class can exploit
this for benefit i don't think the the
working class can exploit that for
benefit
i don't know that that that mode of
analysis is really going to be
that helpful what i can say is that we
we live in a system where capitalism
is not what it was described as in the
past there's a lot of different
capitalisms
and the fact that we live in a system
where for example
um we'll go back to health care right
one reason why the health care system is
as screwed up as it is is not just
because of the
insurance companies which are particular
which are problematic
you know in all sorts of different ways
and which have all sorts of hooks into
lobbying and all that
it's also because hospitals and hospital
groups are allowed to be owned by
uh private equity firms we've had all
this deregulation that has allowed
some really crazy stuff to be going on
and
is there really an old money new money
distinction to be made there i don't i
don't think so i don't think that's
i don't think that's necessarily the
mode of analysis but i could be wrong
you know
this is not like my uh super area of um
research and qualification you know i'm
kind of going off the cuff here
all right um
let's see here fedo says do we
do do i believe that we can actually
overcome the hegemonic influences of
media
specifically right wing that thrives on
spreading paranoia and appeals to
people's worst instincts so
overcome here's the term what do we mean
um any individual
overcome in the sense of like
finding alternate media sources yeah can
we overcome it
in the sense of like totally
discrediting them
and forcing them into the margins so
that they're
basically in the position of like the
john birch society they're they're all
they're for clear nutters who you know
believe in their their stuff you know
the way it was in the 60s and 70s with
the
uh radical fringe in the right probably
not
i i don't think there's i mean i think
again
war of attrition grinding away right
you're not going to write an article
that will take fox news down
that's just not gonna happen um so you
have to think about what you're gonna do
in a world where
all sorts of people buy into this stuff
or stuff that thinks that fox news is
too
you know milk sop for them and they want
the real conservative
the real right stuff you know you notice
that that
trump himself turned against fox news
towards the end of his his regime
um so
no i i don't think you can overcome it
in the sense of like
winning a a war against it
um but i think what what you do is you
try to
like again you know do things on the
local level
you know make sure news stories actually
get out there and get
get um
get traction um and you know
i don't think that that everybody who
voted for trump is sort of irredeemable
you can reach some of them
and wean them away from it but you have
to keep lines of communication open and
be very realistic about what you could
possibly accomplish
you know um so
i i don't i don't know i mean i
the the paranoia worst instinct stuff
that's always been there i mean we see
these these
these moral panics and things like that
going on
years and years and years into the past
and you can look at propaganda
against particular groups in american
media stuff for you know going back to
two
centuries really um
but it is it is it is really um
a problem you know it's so damaging to
the people who buy into it
it's damaging to their own capacity to
operate as a rational human being it's
damaging to their own relationships it's
damaging to their own development
sometimes you can get people weaned away
from that by getting them to see it but
it's like dealing with a drug addict
you know in many respects i think
so all right well that's kind of kind of
dark
um let's see here
rt whitby asses pro racist causality and
stoic and aristotelian texts
oh you you uh heard about the paper i'm
working on
so um rishi says
uh many democrats said they lost votes
due to defund the police slogan do you
buy this and how does the democratic
party navigate being the party
associated with polarizing activists
well i mean both parties are associated
with polarizing activists
there's a lot of polarizing activists on
on the uh
the right aren't there uh including some
of those [ __ ] who
like went into the for example the
michigan legislature armed to the teeth
those are polarizing activists i think
um so i don't think the polarizing
activist thing i think that's kind of a
red herring um defund the police
so
did they lose votes because of that yes
did they also gain votes because of that
yes
who knows what the margins are
everybody's just guessing at that
so i think the narratives that say oh we
lost this seat because of that i think
those are i think those are just
[ __ ] reconstructions after the fact
i don't think there's
any real evidence to support those
claims so i wouldn't take those claims
seriously
that said um defund the police
i don't think is a particularly good
slogan because when you ask
people about it you get one of two
answers so from the people who are
against it and from
some of the people who are for it but
for the wrong reasons they're like yeah
that means get rid of police altogether
and then you're like well okay
we need police what are we gonna do in
lieu of them
um and so that's that's the wrong
answer but but a lot of people read it
that way and i i think
you you can say oh they should know
better well why should they know it
better
you know um the other people
who who are for the slogan will say
what we mean by defund the police is we
want to
tie um the money that the police get to
like performance
objectives and you know uh to things
like having their body cams on
and disciplining bad police and getting
rid of all the proverbial bad apples and
stuff like that
and then you know you could say well
what you really mean is reform the
police
and that's a great slogan you know the
police do need to be reformed that's
clear
i mean this this summer has shown us
that so many police departments are
way out of control that they can't
police themselves
that the the bad apples thing the bad
apples have spoiled the barrel in many
departments
we really do need to have police reform
and any good police officer
would be for police reform and would be
unpopular as a result
that's just a given you know if
you look at what's what's been going on
across the board
you know through through uh uh the
the protests and stuff like that and
there's all sorts of other problems with
with police too you know
things that need to be reformed i've
talked about this a lot before so i
don't have to go into great detail about
it
so if you want if your goal is really to
reform the police
then that should be the slogans that
have defund the police
i don't know what mileage other than
emotional
people are getting out of like demanding
that we
use this slogan instead of that slogan
so i guess i'm you know
i'm not as cynical as obama who seems to
be
you know um very against the the slogan
on that but i i don't see it as
i don't see it as one that's that's um
[Music]
likely to have any
real value going forward so
all right um milo says i agree the biden
team does seem very idealistic
they're idealistic in the respect of
thinking that you can like try to reach
out across the board and maybe not get
your hands slapped back
they're not idealistic in the sense of
like saying that yeah we need a
really new energy policy we need to get
national health care
we need to like you know um do something
about
the environment they're not idealistic
at all they're sort of businesses
as usual so idealistic is is a relative
term right
um rezno says i'm seeing a contingency
of conservatives turning on our uber
conservative governor in georgia
do you think the republican party would
have some sort of break
turning on him for not playing into
trump's fraud narrative i should say
i would love to see
both the the republican and the democrat
party
break up into sub-parties that would be
so awesome
it's not going to happen um i mean the
closest that we had to it was the tea
party
and that tea party effectively took over
the republican party you know
sort of like a cancer metastasizing from
the inside
and that's part of how we got to trump
and and where we are today
um i mean it would be
what we're going to see is is
republicans turning on republicans
but they're all still going to stay
within the same party
and i don't think there's really any
alternative to the democratic party
either
we're stuck in a two-party politics
winner takes all kind of system
and i don't see any way around that
which for me
as somebody who's not happy with either
party but currently is much
much more uh against the the republicans
um than than the democrats um
it's kind of a dismal thing right what
are you gonna do and i'm not gonna like
go to one of the third parties because
like
none of them you know seem seem viable
at all
um so yeah
sean hamill how seriously should we take
terror threats made on pro-trump forums
is it just blusters is this a threat to
life in the republic
um i'd say we should take them seriously
i mean people mean what they say and
they might not have the
the guts to follow through on evil plans
um threatening threatening to to kill
people is pretty pretty
you know the threatening and evil act um
i think that
when people post stuff like that that um
you know we should find ways to do
something about it you know i mean
when it's happening in social media all
you basically have is like
you can report it to the cops and then
if the cops care which
you know who knows depends on your your
local pd doesn't it
um they might do something about it or
you can report it within the social
media
platform i i you know i report tweets
um i don't do much with facebook because
i you know facebook
i don't even like read my facebook
friends stuff anymore
i just have my page and youtube
not much you can do really in youtube um
i just delete the the you know crazy
stuff and banned them from my
my page so i don't have to deal with
them my my rather my youtube channel
um they can go somewhere else but you
know we probably should have some some
takedowns getting the social media
companies to cooperate
that's tough right and they're very
they're very deferential to
high profile accounts i mean think about
trump and his being able to use twitter
basically as a propaganda machine this
entire time he should have been banned
from twitter years ago
um including from making threats right
or or inciting violence you know like
liberate
michigan that should have been the end
of his twitter thing altogether
but it isn't so
all right uh andrew asks any thoughts on
christopher losh and his ideas on the
normalization of narcissism being the
major drive in american culture over the
past century
i've been redlash for years and years
and years so i don't remember the
argument but um i don't think that that
is like the main thing to to be
concerned about
i think that was his hishtick but i
don't um
i mean there's a lot of narcissism going
around on both left and right
and plenty in the center you know a lot
of that goes just under the guise of
consumerism or
you know the identity politics of the
left and the identity politics of the
right i mean anybody who's like
you know remember the good old days when
white people were in charge that's
identity politics you know
just as much as as anything anybody's
doing on
the left and a lot of that is rooted in
narcissism but i don't think that that
saying that particularly helps us
understand what's what's going on you
know
um morgan says you said in another
stream you're not a leftist but you want
the left to push a lot more left-leaning
policies
how do you distinguish yourself from the
left i said i'm not a leftist you know i
don't have a leftist program
um anybody i mean if you want to call me
a left just go ahead and i'll tell you
i'm not
you know that that's about as easy as
you can get
i'm a pragmatist when it comes to this
stuff some of the things the left are
pushing for
are things we need and we should push
and who's going to push for him is the
right going to push for them
i mean some people have made these
arguments like if if trump had wanted
to stay in power forever he could have
not screwed up the coveted response
not bought into all sorts of goofy you
know
q and on [ __ ] you know he could have
condemned
um he could have condemned white power
stuff
and actually let the fbi go after these
groups and he probably would have
he would have taken the wind out of a
lot of sales he can't do it because he's
an [ __ ]
and i mean talk about a malignant
narcissist who
who really just represents some of the
worst stuff about america
corruption you know terrible business
person because he leaves people in the
lurch
he couldn't do it because of his
character right and people on the right
can't push for the sort of things that
they should be pushing for
like protecting the environment or
um you know they they give a lot of talk
to like oh you know
finance capital and blah blah blah blah
but they don't really care about the
average person these politicians of the
the right they're not helping ordinary
people so if the left
is the ones who are going to do it then
i'll line up with them i mean
at other points i said you know what i
am i'm a virtue ethicist
so that means i'm going to work with
whoever is actually putting stuff
forward for the common good
um if it's going to be the left well
then i guess i have to work with the
left
right so if you think that's leftist
i guess you can think that way but it's
kind of kind of silly
um all right
let's see here mother says
seriously i'm working through ptsd
relating to domestic violence
as far as optimistic entries into
tenuous family relations i suggest
looking at non-violent communication not
an endorsement
yeah there's a lot of people working
through through ptsd
i think you know there's all these
things that have been
really inducing it um and
uh not everybody i mean if if
here's here's something i'll say if you
have a family
that imposes like really unfair and
unreasonable demands on you it's okay to
cut them off
it's also okay to say like i'm not gonna
deal with you for a year or two
until i feel more uh strong about
where where i'm coming from maybe i
won't deal with you ever
that's okay i think you know
um kolomos do you think machiavelli
still has swaye or his importance
overstated
um i mean there was a period where it
was very popular
for business people to read
machiavelli's the prince
and it was also very popular at the same
time for them to read sun tzu's art of
war
i don't think they usually understood
either one very well
machiavelli when you read the prince
carefully you notice that he
he says you know the the ordinary people
they're kind of
screw-ups but the rich you really got to
watch those [ __ ] because they are
complete bastards
who love to humiliate and lord it over
the week
the prince had better break or harness
the the the rich the powerful right
um i think he's right about that and i
think rich people
like just read whatever they wanted to
they basically read
hey we should be ruthless and mean and
better to be feared than loved and that
was about
as far as it went um
you know machiavelli is the prince
that's only by the way only a portion of
machiavelli there's also the discourses
on libby where he's much more
bullish on you know the people and
democracy and things like that
um i mean machiavelli's worth reading
just like hobbes is worth reading you
know or aristotle's worth reading
but i don't think he's like got the keys
to anything
um steve have any critiques of chomsky's
political ideas i think i read somewhere
you're not a big fan
i'm not a fan of chomsky um but do i
have any critiques of his political
ideas no i don't have anything
well worked out like that um
milo do you have a favorite political
theorist i mean if there is
a favorite political theorist of mine is
probably aristotle
you know i keep going back to him over
and over and over again
and his political ideas by the way are
found not just in his politics but also
in the rhetoric and also in the two
ethics
and also in other places
as well you know little bits and pieces
here and there but
i don't i don't have a single person who
i may
like aristotelian or hobxia or nietzsche
or something like that and i really do
appreciate people
who are within that tradition
and then come out and and have something
new to say you know because there's a
lot of things where aristotle's just not
you know adaptable to modern systems so
you know alistair mcintyre is great
example
of somebody who is rethinking uh
aristotle
in the present as is um
you know uh some of these people i
mentioned before like gizelle striker
leslie cosman
um you know there's a lot of good work
out there
but i don't and again hannah rent is a
reinterpreter of aristotle as well
i don't think that there's a single
person that i could say that i you know
i'm like i'm not a rosian or a
hobromacian or
anything like that um
giovanni asked do you see senators rubio
and holly as seriously rethinking
conservatives commitment to markets if
they are serious would a conservative
commit to public programs help in our
country in the long run there's nothing
that i see about rubio and i actually
you know i i interact with them
sometimes on twitter of course i don't
get a new response but
and it's mostly poking at him after he
says something stupid and
hypocritical i don't see anything in
rubio that makes me think that
there's anything really going on there
any more than there was with paul ryan
when ryan was supposedly having this
shift away from
ran to saint thomas it all turned out to
be [ __ ] that that disappeared in the
end
um rubio is somebody who
you know if he actually took the
biblical quote seriously that he's like
peppering his twitter stream with he
would resign
or he would he would he'd be going after
his own party
it's it's sort of like the the question
of the cops right um
are there really people who are throwing
the bad apples out
no not really and so if rubio's
criticizing markets
i mean that's not going to last
um unfortunately um
all right d says who are the best
anarchist political philosophers to read
i don't know i'm not not really up on
anarchism
you know um it's not something it's not
something i really
take all that seriously quite frankly
because i'm interested in
how people do exercise power and rule
and and
i've never really been attracted to
anarchism
deprogrammer a lot of people i meet do
not seem to be able to engage with
philosophy yeah i mean i think a lot of
people
can't engage with with actual history
either they they love [ __ ] that they see
on the history channel
or you know military history and they're
like
history buffs this is how they describe
themselves
just like all those people who are like
political you know uh
political junkies anytime somebody
describes himself that way you're like
yeah you don't know a damn thing about
politics and you only follow the little
things that you're paying attention to i
think that's the case with most of the
humanities
and i think that's the case with most of
the sciences doesn't mean that they're
constitutionally incapable
of appreciating or understanding
philosophy it just means that where they
are in their life
that's that's not going to happen so you
know what do we do we
can like curse the darkness or we can
light a candle right
we can say maybe we can reach them with
a bit of philosophy
so like what we do with milwaukee sofia
that's a society of philosophers in
america we have little meetings and
introduce people to ideas and we do so
with kind of baby steps we don't go into
like now i'm going to give you
you know uh a presentation
on the political architectonic or the
the the passional architect tonic
of stasis in aristotle's uh nick uh
politics book five something i've
written out in the past right
um but i can i can talk about um what
anger looks like for aristotle and how
understanding grievance could help us to
master
a bit of anger with ordinary people
and that's doing philosophy right
sometimes i do philosophy and i don't
tell people where it's coming from like
when i work with business people
it's a turn off for them to find out
that the ideas are actually coming from
the stoics or aristotle or thomas
aquinas or
you know mary wollstonecraft if they ask
me afterwards then i say yeah
here's the book you could read about
that but
otherwise i just i present them with the
ideas um
and i think that's that's you know if we
we want people to like the discipline of
philosophy
we got to find ways to hook them you
know
it's in it's interesting some of my
colleagues today
i find this out from from my students
some of my colleagues today
will like still when they're teaching an
intro to philosophy class to non-majors
in college they'll say like if you're
not understanding these texts
there's something wrong with you as a
person and you're like
you've been teaching this for 20 years
has that ever like produced
useful effects for you in the classroom
or are you just indulging yourself
in being kind of a you know
standoffish uh disciplinarian
you know i i take students that i get
and
and i try to get them to be interested
in the ideas and i show them where to go
after we're done with the class to
continue that and that's about as
that's about as much as we can do i
think you know
all right um i just skipped a bit let me
jump back
up because there was a question there
about carl schmidt
um
scrolling scrolling scrolling where is
it
uh i think it was about ogenben as well
uh here we go
from kumar how relevant do you think
carl schmidt and ogan been to the post
911 era
do you see any continuity from fukodian
analysis of power
um okay so there's a couple of questions
there right
let's say this carl schmidt like hobbs
is relevant to the degree that they can
provide
interesting analyses of why we're where
we are
we definitely don't want to follow down
their
rabbit holes and we want to avoid
having to need people like carl schmidt
or hobbes
ogum ben is is interesting he's not
somebody i've read an awful lot of
i think some of his ideas are useful
seems clear that his understanding of
the
covid crisis was way off base um
do i see any continuity from fukudian
analysis of power i mean ogenben
positions himself that way
there couldn't be any from carl schmidt
right because carl schmidt
is is prior to foucault and it depends
on what you mean by foucaulty and
analyses of power
um foucault himself is like kind of all
over the map depending on what book
you're looking at right isn't it
and then there's various ways of
interpreting foucault
in the in philosophy and sociology
criminology
um so it's not as if there's a fucodian
analysis of power so
i don't know i guess i have to punt on
that one
all right um
let's see
dedicated boy what do you think of
julius evola um i don't think much i
haven't really read any evola i've just
read glosses but
seems like everybody that i run into
who's interested in ebola winds up being
a right-wing nut
so that might mean something i don't
know
um raheem is eastern philosophy
where it just skipped inferior to more
popular western ones
i'd get rid of the category eastern and
western to begin with
indian philosophy is as big of a
cultural sphere as is chinese philosophy
as is western philosophy
as is what went on in the islamic world
as is various indigenous things
there is no like east-west thing you
know that's that's the first thing to
get over
um and when you look at you know
european philosophy
you notice that there's a lot of
interactions at certain times with
things that are coming from other places
um inferior no and and
i mean how would you you got like one
set of people on on one side of the
scale and one side on the other
that's it's not a way to do things
you know i think you could say is this
particular philosopher better
this particular philosopher worse or
is this movement or tradition better or
worse
right that's possible i like looking at
where
where they come together you know like
what happened when the jesuits went to
china you
had to rethink things in the face of
this
you know at that point millennia old uh
civilization
and its conceptions of things you know i
i don't i don't find these
big picture contrasts all that useful
all right um
windows smashing job creators what do i
think about direct democracy
uh pretty hard to pull off uh you know
it's it's uh it's tough to even do
within
organizations let alone within
communities it's been done in some
places but it's always on a small scale
um you know when we try to do it like
with
state referendums because of our
political system and how much money
flows into it
it's it's tough to say that it really
does represent the will of the people
and not just who's better able to
advertise
um but i guess it could be done i mean
yeah all right uh alex what do you think
of
hana rent being linked to the congress
for cultural freedom a ci funded
institution does this compromise her
ideas
no it doesn't compromise her ideas i
mean everybody's connected to something
you know dig deep enough and you can
probably find i mean plato
said this right uh justice in this world
is never the form of justice all you got
to do is turn it a little bit on its
side
and you can see some injustice in the
justice it would invalidate her ideas if
it turned out that like they were
feeding her
ideas but um you know did did the
congress for cultural freedom underwrite
uh
her work on totalitarianism if not
probably doesn't have anything to do
with that part right so
no i i don't really care quite frankly
um caa funded a whole bunch of people's
things you know
um all right uh
milo says how important are culture war
issues in your view
well they're absolutely important
you know i mean think about the abortion
issue
and how that
suckered in so many evangelicals and
catholics
into the republican fold and effectively
led them away from christianity
in any real sense and into the weird
parody of it that we see
in conservative catholic and evangelical
churches today
and in their discourses you know i i got
to witness that firsthand because i was
you know i was in those circles and
you'd see these people and they'd be
like the abortion issue has to trump all
the other issues
you know we have to we don't like the
republicans on the economy and on
you know use of force and and stuff like
that but we got to go with them on this
and then after a while they're like well
you know maybe maybe they're actually
not that bad on like
use of force you know and maybe they're
maybe they're pretty good on the economy
and pretty soon
you see people saying things that go
directly against what you thought they
used to stand for
um and now is there is there anything
like that
on the left where people got suckered in
like that
um i mean you know pro-choice catholics
maybe in some respect right and so and
that's just one i mean you could take
all sorts of i would say that that the
coven
whether you wear a mask or not is a
culture war issue
and it shouldn't be right we should all
be
whether whether we think that there's
anything to the mask or not we shouldn't
be indulging in like what's going to
choke you
or you know all this silly [ __ ] that
that people put out there maybe believe
in or maybe they don't
um it shouldn't have become a cultural
war issue but it did become that because
there's so many things
for us that are part of the cultural war
you know all right um
prohem on your story about occupy wall
street is it possible to have groups and
organizations without leaders you can
just elect representatives organizers
for the role of talking to others
okay and and you're going to make a
distinction between
representatives and organizers and
leaders
then right because how is the process
going to work
of getting the message to them and
what degree of discretion do they have
in dealing with with
others right uh at a certain point they
become leaders
or they're or they remain ineffective i
don't think you're going to get around
leaders
you're going to need leadership and then
you've got to watch out for you know
robert michael's iron law of oligarchy
right
which i i actually wrote about that in
response you can find it in auraxis
diana
tk i wrote about that in in response to
hearts
thing years and years ago this would be
like maybe 2014 or so
um all right
uh would wolf wood i don't know if you
addressed this issue earlier but is
trump's denial of the election outcome
some sort of innate psychological trait
or is it nothing more than a grif to get
money and attention i think it's both i
think you've got like a perfect storm
there
you've got a guy who um throughout his
entire life has been screwing people
over
and delighting in it you know for years
and years and years positioning himself
as being this great business leader when
really
he just you know leaves a wake of
bankruptcy and
and uh creditors behind him right
usually unpaid um so he's really
he's been a negative uh effect
uh economically in many respects um
and and that's because of his his
character and the way he likes to be
uh add to it the fact that he he likely
is going to face
all sorts of charges once he's he's out
of office so he's got the like save my
skin
imperative and he will sell out anybody
on the way
and demand loyalty as we've seen on the
way and
add to it the fact that he can't resist
a grift
he he he he seems constitutionally
incapable of not taking advantage of
anything that that he thinks is a
potential deal
um so you know the other thing to add in
there too is is trump is somebody
clearly who believes that it doesn't
matter whether anything's true or false
it's just what you can get people to
believe and so if you can use the legal
system to try to um
you know so doubt and all that then then
he'll do that so i think it's
it the other the other factor is of
course his
uh supporters and enablers and i think
none of them should ever be let off the
hook for anything quite frankly given
the amount of damage
that they have done to to our body
politic and our
our nation um
you can ask what's their what's their
point um the ones who are the more
rational they've already jumped [ __ ]
they've been like this guy's a loser
i better get the hell out of here and
some of them have you know like
positioned themselves as oh i was like
trying to fix it from within
none of them should really be believed
you know they all failed to
to stand up for what was right when when
they could have um
kelly's a great example you know um
so uh yeah there's there's
like i said it's kind of a perfect storm
thing
um all right let's see what else we got
here
uh milo this is a dark one
in a healthcare rationing scenario do
you think anti-vaxxers
should be refused a respirator i don't
think anybody should be
refused a respirator if we have enough
respirators
to go around i i'm
attracted to the idea because i do think
that that we do need to have some sort
of
justice for um taking willfully taking
stupid self-indulgent indulgence stances
i would say not just anti-vaxxers but
also the
anti-mask people but how are you gonna
do that practically
you know um i i don't think that that's
it's attractive as an idea i don't think
it could be
it could be done in any sort of way that
would be effective or fair so
you know we're probably we probably
shouldn't try to do that
um alex i'm dying to know what this guy
thinks about jacques
martin's politics in person haven't read
politics in person
read a lot of other maritime stuff from
earlier and uh
maritan was by the way kind of a bad guy
for a while he was
a member of accion francaise the fascist
proto-fascist integral nationalist
organization
until it got condemned by the vatican in
26 and and maritime went through some
changes and iterations of his doctrine
um
but he could be kind of a prick at times
you know not as big of a prick as garage
lagrange who would like
criticize people without without
admittedly being able to understand
their work
but you know i'm not a big fan of
maritime
quite frankly
all right uh rolled on my thoughts on
personalism as a political alternative
to modern individualism collectivism
i i think it's probably a non-starter
personalism names a whole bunch of
approaches in philosophy whose
personalism are you talking about shaler
von hildenbrand martin luther king
and what are you identifying as
individualism collectivism it's going to
be some crazy abstraction
that doesn't map on all that well to
whatever we've got going on
i don't think these categories are
particularly helpful
all right um shiny pop-tarts should we
entertain
questions regarding election fraud what
do we do with various evidence that that
has arisen
okay so this is a good question we
entertain the question so long as it's
reasonable to do so we've passed the
point of reasonability a long time ago
you know um you're always in in an
election
with you know a country of hundreds of
millions of people
you're gonna find some instances of
of fraud right you'll find that even in
a local thing the question is how much
and did it do anything and so at a
certain point
the people who are if they were patriots
if they cared about a common good
at a certain point the people who were
talking about oh there could be some
fraud
need to sit down and shut the hell up if
they care
otherwise they're just in it to try to
stir [ __ ] up
you know and we've long passed that
point
it i mean case after case after case
after case
some of the the recounting happened just
a block from here
you know um and i got to see the the nut
jobs and you could tell by the wild look
in their eyes you know these
these republican observers going in and
the crazy makeup and all that sort of
crap
you know it's done
the republicans need to accept that and
then move on
and if they don't then they're just
playing politics
right and it's the same way for the
culture
all right um the programmer good thing
we have democracy so this guy can't pack
the cops
uh yeah yeah you're so clever
glad you're here what a dumb thing to
say
all right uh sean hamler comparisons
with the roman republic helpful or
unhelpful
pretty much unhelpful the the difference
between
our circumstances and that of ancient
rome
are so vast it's it's not really helpful
we need to look for
nearer things for years and years and
years
i have been saying that if we want to
find close closer parallels
you really want to read william shires
the
fall of the french third republic
because a lot of the things
that you know france people are people
have this very distorted view about
about uh
recent european history because you know
the the french uh fell apart so quickly
with the nazi blitzkrieg they forget
that france was dominant
militarily after world war one despite
having lost an entire generation of
young men
and that if they'd wanted to they could
have nipped germany in the bud at many
different points they actually had
germany encircled
with military alliances which then they
didn't follow through
it and what what killed them two things
one was the the the
generals being unwilling to to risk
things
but also political discord political
discord
run by parties both on left and right
who thought that they knew best and that
that they should undermine things by the
way you remember me mentioning accion
frances
they played a role in that you know so
i would i would look at uh not rome but
the french third republic
all right um
let's see here
[Music]
kirby do you think conspiracy theories
will become should be
a serious subject of attention and
epistemology
they already are there's people that
have been researching this for for
decades
um as a matter of fact even in critical
thinking textbooks i'm pointing over
there because that's where my old ones
were from fayetteville state um that was
a thing that we would discuss
in in critical thinking classes so
all right um
let's see here a lot of off topic stuff
about different things um
here we go michael frank earlier you
mentioned you didn't think the federal
system was working
can you explain a little bit what you
mean by that what ways isn't it working
i didn't say the federal system per se
wasn't working
what i said was that it hadn't done
stuff in terms of covet if i remember
right
it it could have been working but it but
it didn't because we had the wrong
person
in there um
let me take a question by far amok
that's off base aristotle and his
politics deemed slavery as ideal and
practical
and his teacher to alexander whose
adventurism in persia ended up being
short-lived
totally wrong if you actually read
aristotle instead of glosses on
aristotle
you will see that he actually says that
most slaves
shouldn't be slaves there are some
people that he says would be natural
slaves and they would only be
natural slaves if they are benefited by
being slaves
and they have a superior master does
aristotle think that most greeks are
superior masters
read the nick of mccain ethics read the
politics see what he says about things
this is this is like totally off base
and as a matter of fact aristotle
criticized alexander
for his treatment of barbarians
and his attempt to have an oikomenike um
with with blending greek and persian
cultures so
you know i don't know where you got your
ideas but you probably want to actually
read the aristotle
um all right
johnny bowie s we need an ai run
healthcare system that sounds terrible
i can't i mean i i know a lot of ways
you could make it worse
and that's probably got to be up in the
top five
i i don't imagine given all the problems
with ai already that
an ai run healthcare system is going to
be particularly good
ken says what the us really needs is
national health service the concept
has its faults but healthcare is free at
the point of consumption takes away 95
percent of the concerns
of illnesses yeah i mean you don't have
to have a perfect
system you just have have to have a
system that is better
than what we've got in place right now
which is a non-system it's a
whole set of screwed up not well
functioning interlocking systems
we don't really have a system so yeah
all right uh shiny pop-tart does
socrates criticism of democracy of
relevance to the current political
situation in america
thinking specifically of the biden
harris administration's emphasis on
democratic rhetoric
i would say not much relevance at all
you're talking about what's in there in
in republic book book eight
um that's a a very different kind of
democracy than what we we have at
present or what we think of as
as democracy i guess you could say the
closest thing that that comes to it is
the notion of the the democratic regime
being um a pointy layer you know uh
we could say multifarious regime
where people are allowed to do what they
want but that's not particularly biden
i mean that could just the republicans
just as much want
they they talk about freedom you know i
want to be able to
go to the the barber shop and stuff like
that that's that's just as much in that
what socrates would be talking about
this sort of like
unbridled uh freedom that doesn't care
about effects on other people
um so i i don't see it as particularly
relevant i i would say other other
theorists would be more relevant
um
let's see
john okay i've already i'm gonna see if
i can take some people that haven't
already been here
uh immortals proud what do you think
about the idea we live in a
post-truth era based on the idea that
social media
gives people what they want to hear and
confirmation bias is more present than
ever i don't know if confirmation bias
is more
present than ever i would say the modes
of it are different
right and do we live in a post-truth era
it depends
on you know who we are and what sort of
stuff we're consuming
um i mean you could say that we're
forced to live in a post-truth era
in that a lot of people
[Music]
when you get down to it are sort of
living as if they're in a post-truth era
and then it's sort of like the
you know nothing succeeds like you know
success
sort of thing um i know that there's
plenty of us who don't
view things that way who think that
truth actually still does matter
um so
i don't know i i i'm kind of divided on
on that one
um okay let's see here
[Music]
there's a good point from the programmer
there's a difference between being
afraid and vigilant let's be vigilant i
like that yeah
yeah um
uh let me skip down here a bit
so brianna brings up a question that's
sort of similar to the one i took at the
start what advice would you give to
someone who's common sense progressive
but had close family who voted trump and
or his fans until the bitter end our
household seems polarized and in need of
repair
so i think that you might have to accept
that your household might not get
repaired you know um it's a live
possibility that
some of the people who went like all in
on on trump
um and bought into like you know all the
this is so good and this is so good and
this is so good and these are so bad
sort of rhetoric you might never see
them come out of it
um that's kind of you know it's kind of
a
strong possibility so
all right let me
see what else we have um
oh here's a good one from reservoir duck
i don't understand how trump's voters
see trump as an altruistic
figure sacrificing himself for the
common good he seems an obvious
narcissist and fraud
any thoughts on how people reach this
yeah
it never happens with like a switch
flipping they have to go in
bit by bit by bit by bit i mean it's
weird too to like see these things where
people have
memes where trump is this muscular
figure when actually he's just a huge
you know blob um who can't even like
stand like a human being he's got
such weird posture because he's got to
have like elevators in his shoes to make
himself look like he's a bigger guy
um i you know this this is part of why
it's so difficult to wean people away
from this
it didn't just happen with one i you
know one
moment or one idea it's all sorts of
things that have consolidated something
that we can call a habitus
you know a hexis in greek uh and this is
like what aristotle you know
talks about vices are hexays you know
and that doesn't just mean habit it
means like a lasting disposition that
has been formed that deforms
not just how you respond but how you
feel
how you interpret as nancy sherman talks
about this
um vices and virtues change
what we view as ethically salient what
we view as
mattering you know and how we how we
view things
so yeah it's it's uh
it's gonna be weird to see people trying
to um
to get away from this once their great
leader is
is uh gone and some of them are always
gonna believe that he was a
wonderful man you know but you know we
can see stuff like this with like if you
again look at reese
at french history there was this guy
pujad who when when
trump first came on the scene i was like
that's pujod again you know
um and there there are still people
today who are like oh it was a great man
you know
so you're never going to see that go
away um
edmund burke asks a local question what
do i think about marquette's recent
cutting faculty i think it's totally
shameful
i think that marquette uh quit being a
catholic institution in
any real respect at least 20 years ago
um they certainly don't live up to their
catholic and jesuit ideals
and they while i was still teaching for
them part time i saw them cut the
core where you have philosophy and
theology to the bare minimum
possible they've been selling themselves
out
for you know professional schools you
know the school of law
engineering the big big ticket stuff
business school for years
they they quit being what they were uh
decades ago and if marquette wanted to
not cut those jobs they easily could
they have a 700 million dollar endowment
which they could easily tap into they
own real estate all over the milwaukee
area which they could sell
it's a deliberate choice to to cut the
faculty and to cut the faculty in
certain areas
to change the nature of the school
but that's what you get when you have a
board of trustees and
administrators who do not care anything
about catholic education
so all right let's see if we can grab
one more
thing um
and then we'll end because i've gotta
get back to grading
the worst part about being a professor
ah here's a good one from ashmar should
can philosophers become more directly
involved in national politics and
forming policy lawyers and business
people always run for office and get
admin positions never philosophers
philosophers have
but it's pretty rare and you know
should they get involved with national
politics how do you do that nationally
if you haven't done it locally first you
have to do local
politics and there we i mean i've known
people in my
philosophy departments who've held
political office um
or who were involved at least in in
races and then they lost
so i think if if we're going to do that
we have to
train them up you know and
um you know that's
that's going to take a lot of time i
don't think a lot of people in
philosophy are particularly
into doing that work but um
that's uh yeah
i mean i'm not gonna do it i i i'm busy
enough with the stuff that i do
i i can i'm willing to be involved in
politics in the sense of like writing
letters and calling people
and things along those lines
somebody's up on the roof hammering but
i'm not
you know i'm not interested in running
for office um but i'm willing to support
other people who
who are you know that takes a lot of
time
and a lot of attentiveness so
that's a good thing to end on um thanks
to all of you for
joining joining me i might do something
later in the week
you know maybe like a pop-up
uh around christmas time for those who
you know want to hang out for
for a little bit and maybe have a toast
or something like that
um but now it's back to
grading hell which is going to continue
most of the rest of the weekend i might
get a walk in a little bit later
to clear my head but um
still have a lot of final grades to do
so all right
i'll see all of you and take it easy